PROFESSOR: The elements
that have inverses modulo
and will be particularly
important to us.
And so the first
question is how many of
them are there, which is what
Euler's function tells us.
So the definition of
Euler's function, phi of n,
is it's the number of
integers in the remainder
interval from 0
to n minus 1 such
that k is relatively prime to n.
So remember, there's the
notation for the remainder
interval that includes
0 and excludes n.
And another way to say
relatively prime to n
is to say the gcd
of k and n is 1.
So let's define
that set of numbers
that we're interested
in-- gcd1 of n [? be ?]
those numbers that
have a gcd of 1 with n.
That is, the numbers that have
inverses and the numbers that
are cancellable modulo n.
So what it means
is that phi of n
is precisely equal to
the size of gcd1 of n.
Now, some authors
call gcd1 n star.
I didn't find that a
very informative notation
and so I'm not using it.
phi of n is also, for
your information, called
Euler's totient
function, but we'll just
stick to calling it
phi or Euler's phi.
So let's look at an
example-- gcd1 of 7.
The numbers that are
relatively prime to 7
are all the positive numbers
less than 7 because 7 is prime.
So it's the set
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
gcd1 of 12 is the
numbers that have
no factor in common with 12.
They are the numbers
in green below.
And the other red
numbers do have
a number in common with 12-- do
have a prime in common with 12.
The pattern here
is not so apparent.
Anyway, phi of 7 is the
size of gcd1 of 7-- namely
the size of the set 1
through 6, which is 6.
gcd 12 determines
phi of 12. phi of 12
is the number of green
elements, which is 4.
OK.
A simple rule for
calculating phi.
When phi is prime we've
already indicated,
namely, everything--
every positive number
less than p is
relatively prime to p.
And so phi of p is
simply p minus 1.
Let's look at a more
important example,
or illustrative example--
namely, phi of 9.
Well, OK.
So there are the
candidate numbers from 0
through 8, and which ones
are relatively prime to 9?
Well, it's relatively
prime to 9 if and only
if it's relatively prime to 3.
Now, which numbers
in this interval
are relatively prime to--
are relatively prime to 3,
or, rather, are not
relatively prime to 3?
Well, it's every third
number that's divisible by 3.
So, those are the bad ones.
If we subtract the bad ones,
we're left with the good ones--
the ones that are
relatively prime.
So a phi of 9 is simply
the set of all the numbers
minus 1/3 of 9, which is the
bad one-- bad one's namely 6.
This generalizes to
a power of a prime.
If k is a positive
integer then phi of p
to the k-- the reasoning is
that a number is relatively
prime to the p to
the k if and only
if it's relatively prime to p.
p divides every pth
number, so one pth
of the numbers in
the interval are bad,
which means that phi of p is
the good ones minus 1 pth of p
to the k.
Namely, phi of p to the k is
p to the k minus p to the k
over p, which can
also be expressed
in a more standard
form-- p to the k
minus p to the power k minus 1.
And that knocks off
the story of phi
to the p for powers of primes.
Well, suppose you're
dealing with a number that's
not a power of a prime.
And there's one very elegant
little fact about phi
that explains how to deal
with non powers of primes.
Namely, if a and b
are relatively prime,
then phi of a b is simply
gotten by computing phi of a
and multiplying it by phi of b.
This property of phi is called
multiplicativity, by the way.
It comes up a lot
in number theory.
A function is
multiplicative when
its value at a product of
relatively prime numbers
is the product of the
values at those two
relatively prime numbers.
So phi is multiplicative.
Now, the proof of that-- one
proof is on problem set 5,
and there's another proof that
we'll see in a couple of weeks
when we get into counting the
inclusion-exclusion principle.
Let's just use this
fact about phi--
the multiplicity of phi--
multiplicativity of phi
to see how it lets us calculate
phi of an arbitrary number.
So, in particular, phi of
12-- which looked complicated
earlier-- well, 12 is 3 times 4.
So that means that phi of 12
is phi of 3 times phi of 4.
But now I'm in great
shape because 3
is a power of a prime,
namely 3 to the 1.
And 4 is a power of a
prime, namely 2 squared.
So applying the power of prime
formulas, I get that phi of 3
is 3 times 1 times 2 squared
minus 2 to the 2 minus 1,
which simplifies to 4, which is
the answer that we saw before.
And the punchline for
why we're examining phi
is Euler's theorem,
which tells us
how powers of numbers
in gcd1 of n behave.
Namely, that if k is
relatively prime to n, then
if you raise k to
the power phi of n,
it's congruent to 1 mod n.
And that will lead us.
In the next section we
will look at the proof
of Euler's theorem.